c'est votre prétention et le mépris
c'est à dire que voilà vous êtes
monsieur livre au livre sait jamais si
c'est vrai une seule fois une olive ou
deux animés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
prenez-en 2
et
donc voilà vous vous dites qu'il ya des
pauvres imbéciles qui respecte qui ils
sont vous croyez que ça amuse tous les
gens qui font kathak l'isolément non on
a tous des problèmes ils ont tous des
problèmes mais moi je suis plus
intelligent tout le monde à ses pieds il
ya des gens ici qui restent près de cinq
jours était d'être imbécile doit excuser
moi et non à arrêter avec ce
gouvernement prend des mauvaises
décisions donc moi je suis venu et je
les applique mais c'est un mépris pour
les autres et une prétention mais c'est
bon ben voilà qu'on croissance acquis
mais pousse développeurs pour tous les
gens qui suivent lewis et moi les autres
au mépris de coude de salé frisson dans
la rue tout seul
je l'accordé à
bcg les commissions qui sont ils qu'est
ce que vous croyez qu'ils fassent qui
sort mais non je suis déjà tous les
moyens de se faire livrer des kwassas
des interviews ya plein de gens c'est
parce que vous restiez à seynod saison
gouvernementale et son trio on a
en a ras-le-bol de votre compte vous
comprenez situe pile le jour j 2 mais je
semais
bbc l'a pas laissé le parler tient neuf
millions de personnes qui vont perdre
leurs postes sanitaires là le 15 février
parce qu'ils vont pas faire leur
troisième de
covin on en a ras-le-bol
et vous changerez les lois pour
l'instant vous êtes un citoyen et vous
êtes un citoyen qui vous pour la mettre
sous toit qui s'insurge un peu plus
notre pays qu'on arrête de suite
maintenant les docks tunisair demande à
tout le monde faisait comme vous ça qu'a
fait sa loi et banque populaire vont
s'en tirer mieux vaut la peine
ciné par cette personne et non mais
c'est pas compliqué c'est con parce
qu'il voulait vous suivre toute une
heure
c'est con mais elle est émouvante